Wanda starts off this hour in Charlotte
North Carolina
I wonder how are you I'm doing great
thank you
how come well I'm I become a widow when
I was 49 and I retired at the age of 49
also I worked for the state and since
that time I have made very poor
decisions financially and I have got
myself very much in that hold our you
know I'm 60 mm-hmm okay so I was the
last 11 years then yes okay and how much
debt do you have kiddo everything
including the two houses I have in my
car
266 pounds okay and when you retired
from the state the driven income that is
provided Union okay and I'm going to
draw on what you make them eyes on Darla
1350 from estate and then I draw 850
from a portion of my husband's pension
and then I draw my social security at
1350 okay and I get $600 rent on the
house gotcha all right and the 266 let's
break that down you have two houses I do
I've been trying to sell the other one
my so you're just going along the back
there's a little lesson it's a rental my
husband was murdered there and I can't
find anybody that well by oh my goodness
gracious
well 11 years later though um so what is
the house huh it's worth right around
120,000 okay all right you have it on
the market with a real estate agent I
have in the past and I like selling it
yeah you don't know okay and what do you
owe on that 180 thousand
okay all right and would you agree with
me that that house is no longer a
blessing no it's no longer bless if you
could just get out even you'd get rid of
it I don't want to but I wanted to it's
time for that thing to go away for a lot
of reasons it's hanging over your head
emotionally hanging over your head
financially you you fret about it it is
a problem child does that make sense
it makes a lot of food yeah I want rid
of that thing if I'm you if you were my
older sister you'd be just barely over
because that we're about the same age
I'd be going sis get rid of that thing
it's a pain in the butt so let's get a
real estate agent on the phone jump on
Dave Ramsey comm click on the LP for
real estate get one of our top flight
high octane people over there let's get
this thing priced and if you price it at
ninety nine nine it'll sell okay and
because you know there's no evidence in
there physically of of the tragedy that
occurred there is there no okay
so it's just only people listen there's
so many people move to Charlotte last 11
years then we know this happened and own
thinking thing about it so if it was a
small town it you know it would be a it
would be harder but to break the
reputation of the crime that occurred
but there's a lot of turnover here
you're going to be fine you need to get
this thing a priced and to sell and get
rid of it's got a renter in it I do okay
is it some kin of yours no good all
right let's get this thing on the market
get it sold and if you pay the rent or a
little bit extra to get them out or
whatever that's fine let's get rid of
that that helps all right now how much
do you owe on your home well I uh
hundred and twelve thousand on the house
um and I made a very bad mistake and got
a second mortgage to pay off credit
cards mm-hmm and how much do you owe on
the second mortgage thirty thousand okay
and how much do you have okay so that's
what we were
50 and then 80 is so you got about
another $30,000 in debt somewhere else
on what credit cards or cars you said
how many cars do you have yeah like I
said I make very bad decisions
I have to okay
and tell me about it what do you owe on
them uh one that I bought last year
thirty thousand and I'm upside down oh
yes and are the one another emotional
thing my husband bought it for me right
before he died and I use the title to
earn money to pay off credit and how
much do you owe on it
six thousand what is it probably worth
it's probably not worth because it's a
2002 in just working it's probably worth
about three or four thousand okay all
right okay okay well sound like we got a
couple cars we need to sell and get you
a little three thousand dollar paid for
car with no car payments and get rid of
the rental and suddenly there's going to
start to be some room in this budget if
you did that wouldn't $30,000 are kiddo
you can't keep a $30,000 car and I
doesn't fit I know I don't
it was just one of them emotional yeah I
know but it was done yeah you can't keep
it no okay
let's get rid of it let's get rid of
that and we'll get rid of the other you
need somebody to hold your hand and walk
with you through this and love you
enough to tell you the truth and give
you the strength to do what you already
have a good common sense to do because
you can lose your common sense you're
just hurting your heart was broken
ripped out of your chest eleven years
ago and you're still somewhat recovering
from that am I wrong no no okay kiddo I
understand I will be painful I can't
imagine what you've been through so
here's what we're going to do we've got
counselors that have been trained by us
financial coaches trained by us all
right I'm going to pay for it I will
cost you a thing widows
don't pay here all right and I can't put
you on hold and Kelly's going to pick up
and we're going to one of our coaches
meet with you and they're going to put
their arm around you and they're going
to walk you through this and if you
don't walk they're gonna kick your butt
okay because we love you we want you to
win okay it's time for you to get some
of this behind you and get control again
because it's starting to own you isn't
it yes it is yeah okay that ends today
you called the right guy I got the
antidote kiddo all right okay you hold
on I'll have Kelly pick up and we'll get
you signed up here Kelly also make sure
that we know what local church she's
plugged into and if she's not let's get
a pastor around her okay got a bunch of
good ones in the Charlotte that we can
plug her in with this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]